[Music]
hello
and welcome to chess openings explained
i'm your instructor nick risco
and tonight we're going to be going over
the vienna game
and the vienna gambit we're going to see
how much we can get through
this one may be a two-parter
but with that being said let's just jump
right into it
we have a e4 e5 and the vienna
is characterized by this move knight to
c3
and this move may seem a little
interesting to some newer players
normally if they have a coach or someone
who's teaching them how to play they'll
tell them to play knight
f3 and target this weak pawn right away
however knight to c3 is also a good move
some may say it's a little more passive
but this is
actually a pretty good move if you're
trying to break open the center
very early on some of white's plans may
include bishop to c4
pawn to f4 breaking open in the center
with
rapid development and quick attacks
from here black has two main options
by developing either knight to the
center
so we'll go over one uh each of them in
depth but we'll give a little overview
right now first we'll take a quick look
at knight f6
and from knight f6 you can get the
vienna gambit
which is pawn to f4 after pawn to f4
white is giving black the option to take
in exchange
for a strong center and rapid piece
development so let's take a quick look
at what happens if black takes after
black takes
white kind of wants to take a look at
black's position and say
your knight is a bit vulnerable here and
play e5 right away after white plays e5
there's really only one good square for
this knight to go and that is to
undevelop
and go right back to g8 and from here
white can continue with normal
development knight f3
pawn goes to d6 and here
there's a couple little small moves
where white can go wrong
first off white does not want to take
this center pawn
you might think well we just lost the
pawn i just want to get it back by
taking on d6
but this can actually have white hurt
themselves
the bishop can take on d6 and now even
though
you know material is looking fine uh for
white
yeah you're down a pawn but this f4 pawn
is weak this bishop developing to d6
will help anchor this
f4 pawn and also more importantly
helps black develop their pieces and
this is not what we want as white we're
trying to maintain every little edge we
have and giving black
some free play with his pieces isn't
going to help us
so instead of taking on d6 what white
will do
is play pawn to d4 and black will often
take
they're up material they want to trade
off pieces this is fine
and again white needs to be careful here
they can't just
take on e5 with the pawn because of
queen takes d1 and then knight takes d1
let's say white wants to make sure they
can castle later
knight c6 bishop takes f4 you get your
pawn back from the beginning
and then after bishop e6 black really
does have
some development here knight on c6
bishop on e6
are really going to let black get some
control
over the position they're going to
castle queenside where white still needs
to develop the bishop can't go to c4
anymore so it might go to b5
they may castle king side but in the
long run this isolated king's pawn is
going to be
a big target that black is going to hit
so taking back with the d-pawn i can't
recommend it
so what do you do if you can't take back
the pawn you might as well pin it
pin it with the queen queen pins the
pawn to the king so they cannot take on
d4
obviously the queen can't take on d4
because of the knight
so black is going to struggle with this
e5 pawn
so now i'm going to give the viewers a
little chance to see if black can defend
this pawn
or if they can't defend it and should
focus on something else
okay so for those of you who say you
should give it up and focus on something
else good for you
there's a couple problems if black tries
to
hold on to this pawn so let's go over
the the tries one by one let's imagine
they go
f6 and they push the f pawn trying to
protect e5
this goes against ben feingold's rule
book never play f6
it's just horrible for black and we'll
see why here
in just a second white will just take on
e5 anyway
and if the pawn recaptures there's many
moves that white can play here they can
take with the knight they can take with
the queen
but i really like bishop takes f4 just
saying hey
your pawn's actually hanging this is
still pinned i'm going to take it on my
next turn
and wipe you off the board so f6
doesn't work here what if they try
with bishop to d6 well very similar
story you just take on f4
and the pawn is hanging and you're going
to take e5 next
okay well if you can't do that so let's
take a look at knight c6
story doesn't change bishop takes f4
but here you might notice you know what
what if black takes on d4 it looks like
they have three attackers
and white only has one defender so what
if the knight takes on d4
and this is actually a blunder for black
all because after knight takes d4 queen
takes d4
there is bishop takes e5 a very
potent move here the queen is still
on the king so there's a lot of
discoveries the bishop is pointing at
the queen so the queen has to move
and let's say the queen moves to safety
let's say the queen goes to b6
there is bishop takes g7 check the queen
is
attacking the king and the bishop is
going to win the rook
in the corner so this knight to c6 idea
also does not work
i believe those are all the main tries
black can have if they want to try and
hang onto e5 but again
it's just not the best idea for black
black really needs to focus on their
piece development and their piece
activity
so you're more likely to find black
playing a move like bishop to b4 here
after bishop to b4 they're pinning the
knight kind of loosening white's control
over the center
then after a queen takes e5 queen e7
white should not just trade into an end
game this can actually lead to some
problems so let's say queen e7 knight e7
uh now bishop to uh sorry his whites
move rather
there's bishop f4 you get your pawn back
but uh bishop to c3
uh these doubled pawns they're
they can be good or bad but it's better
to stick with something more flexible as
white you don't want to commit to a pawn
structure like this which can
easily go wrong
um instead white just has a simple
bishop takes up for
developing another piece keeping control
in the center
if the queen takes white can take with
either minor piece
here is actually just forking some pawns
so this line with uh accepting the
gambit
probably not the best try for black
so that was just our little overview of
the knight f6 and the vienna gambit
obviously there are other lines black in
play that we will go over
in a little bit the other
move black has is knight to c6
and after knight to c6 you get the
vienna game there is no gambit
white isn't going to go for f4 here and
the reason is that after f4
and uh e takes f4 white does not have
this e5 push anymore
uh tempoing a knight in fact black can
just try and take it right away
here it doesn't exactly work because of
queen e2 you need to protect the knight
and there there really is no great way
to do it once the knight moves
uh you hit with d4 so once the queen
blocks you can play d4
and black just kind of gets their pieces
out there
trading off the queens is going to help
benefit black because white is not
up in development compared to the other
positions
so you don't have e5 here so
f4 not the best move instead white has
the very sharp bishop g or sorry bishop
c4
and let's say black is just copying
their opponent
a lot of beginner players will copy
their opponent thinking it's a great
idea
but here if they go bishop to c5 this
leads to a very very tough position
right away and this is what is known as
the copycat variation
and white can win or get a close to
winning position
right with queen to g4
i'll let this position sink in for a
little bit here as i pull up
my notes
okay so queen to g4 what exactly is
happening in this position
the main threat is the g7 pawn
and there can be some problems for black
if they try and focus on other things
uh let's say black wants to keep copying
their opponent's strategy and move their
queen as well they go queen f6
yeah you're protecting the pawn but here
white has
a very very cool move uh i really like
this move
is knight to d5 you're hitting c7
you're hitting f6 but
in return you're letting black capture
on f2 with the queen
and this is not mate here because the
queen is not on d1
after black takes on f2 the king goes to
d1
and slowly black may start to realize
you know
oh hey the the queen is hitting g7 the
knight is hitting c7
how do you protect both of these not to
mention
if black plays something very passive
let's say they try and go
g6 to protect the g pawn this blunders
right away because it traps the queen
you have knight to h3 and you'll notice
the entire f-file
is controlled by pawns and minor pieces
every single square on the f-file e3 is
protected by a pawn and knights so the
queen can only go to d4
and then after queen to d4 there's the
move d3
and there's no way to stop c3 from
coming so the only move
black really has here is to move the
bishop to b6 or e7
and then after like bishop to e7 the
queen comes to
f3 queen f3 puts on some pressure
you're looking at knight takes c7 and a
discovery
uh and also knight g5 just sinking the
knight into the position can also give
white a very promising position
okay so if black cannot play g6
what does black have here in the copycat
variation
have a couple tries but the main move is
king to f8 you have to protect g7 you
don't want to lose a rook
it's much better just to lose the pawn
on c7
here white continues with knight two h3
hitting the queen and here black has
this in-between movement innomezo or
zuishenzuk
where they can play h5 and attack
white's queen
now trading queens here in this position
probably will not benefit white they
might still have a better position
but this queen is so close to being
trapped you want to maintain that for as
long as possible so instead of going
something like queen f3
or queen g3 where you can get your pawns
doubled white will just go
queen to g5 and say hey my queen is safe
here on g5
your queen still has to move and here
there's
three tries for black only one of them
gives black
close to even game the first try can be
pawn to f6
trying to attack the queen again here
the queen goes to g6
and after rook to h6 there's a very
tactical move
knight e7 white
is threatening checkmate on f7 and yes
they're hanging the queen but
don't forget this entire time black's
queen has been hanging
so if rook takes g6
knight g6 comes with check the king
cannot go to f7 because of the bishop
so after the king moves then white takes
on
f2 black takes on f2 white takes on g8
and here white just has a very promising
position the knight and bishop are close
to the king
kind of keeping them tied in black still
needs to spend moves to develop the
light squared bishop
white has rook to f1
d3 very quickly bringing the bishop to
e3 possibly
very easy development for white so f6 i
don't recommend this for black
i just want to be clear i don't
recommend the copycat variation for
black
but what's another try for black here
they can try bishop to e7
attacking the queen right away but
there's just knight takes e7
and white is winning here there's no way
to recapture and threaten the queen
again
and the queen is still hanging so you
may think you have
queen to f6 but here just trade
and then take on you know c8 or c6 maybe
either should be fine you're going to go
up a piece
so if f6 and bishop e7 don't work the
only move left really
is queen to d4 bringing it to the safe
square early
now here white can still try pawn to d3
um
but here there's bishop e7 counter
attacking the queen
and the key move for white to remember
here is to go queen to g3
if they don't go queen to g3 they can
run into some problems like if
knight takes e7 i played this in a game
recently while preparing for this
lecture you can't make this trade after
the knight takes back black really
starts to get their pieces developed and
without your knight on d5 you lose a lot
of the pressure
in the position so you have to remember
queen g3
and after knight f6 you can go upon c3
attacking the queen
the queen goes to c5 and now in the
spirit of
this vienna opening instead of capturing
on c7 going for little pawns
you're going to keep going for the piece
activity
and here we see white go rook to f1
keeping an eye on the f file the knight
shouldn't really take after bishop d5 f7
is really weak and if you play f6
well queen g6 and you're going to be
threatening mate
and uh if you have to play knight d8 uh
if your opponent makes you play knight
d8 you're not having a very fun time
so we'll go back that's uh pretty much
it for the copycat variation there
where the opponent goes bishop c5
copying white
so instead of bishop c5 what should
black do here there's a couple different
options
we'll start off with d6 it kind of
reminds me a bit of a philidor position
except your knight is on c3 instead of
f3 and here
white can just play pawn to d3 and have
a very
easy time developing you can go bishop
e3
go knight to g to e2 castle king side
play for an eventual
f4 very easy development
and the plus is that white's bishop is
outside the pawn chain where black's
bishop is inside of the pawn chain
so d6 has some positional drawbacks and
the plan is very hard
for for black or it's not as easy as
white's plan
so instead of d6 black can try
knight f6 and this one also is a very
serious
move for black here if white's not
careful they can find themselves in
trouble
but play shouldn't be too difficult
after pawn d3
and here black has a decision to make
they can play
bishop to c5 or they can play knight to
a5
the idea with knight to a5 is you're
hitting the bishop
and if white uh moves the bishop back
black will easily get the bishop pair
uh and again in the vienna white's just
going for peace activity
so they go knight g to e2 they allow
this trade of pieces
getting a weak weaker center pawn
and after bishop to c5 black gets some
peace activity
white can castle d6 looking to develop
the bishop maybe to g4
queen to d3 kind of protecting this
c4 pawn over protecting the e4 pawn
after you move the bishop you'll have
your rooks connected so queen d3 nice
centralizing move
bishop to e6 attacking the pawn
and now b3 just solidifying everything
kind of
telling black their bishop is not great
on this diagonal
staring into a wall of pawns black will
castle king's side and this position
is equal for both sides black has the
bishop pair but the position
isn't really open the light square
bishop
is black's theoretical good bishop it's
on the opposite color square of their
pawns
however white's pawns control all the
light squares so if black can trade off
some pawns this may prove well for black
if they can't white can go in for a
quick king side attack after something
like king h1 and f4
so that's the knight a5 idea just
getting the bishop pair right away
the other idea is bishop to c5 and
before bishop to c5 wasn't great because
of queen g4 but now with the knight on
f6
this is no longer possible so white
needs to look for a better move and
here they can go oops they can go
pawn f4 pawn f4 they can strike in the
center
and now if they take some of these e5
ideas
may come back into play in the future
but here
just bishop takes f4 keep developing
quickly
is going to do just fine for white if
they take
that being said black doesn't take often
they play d6
try and keep their center strong looking
to develop the light square bishop to g4
where it can tempo the queen
and castle king's side the main move is
knight f3
that way if bishop g4 it doesn't come
with tempo
and here black has two options
the first option they have is bishop to
g4
and after bishop to g4 we get some very
interesting ideas
this can lead to a very sharp game i'm
going to show you this very fun line
here
knight to a4 kind of the same idea
in the previous line where black goes
knight to a5
white is just looking to get the bishop
pair and enjoy a nice space advantage
after a move like f5
bishop to b6 knight takes the a pawn
takes
giving the rook an open file
castles from both sides pawn to c3 and
now you'll notice this kind of looks
like an italian
or a spanish pawn structure except pawns
on f4
f4 is an idea you might see in both of
those games
but d4 is another push to consider
so to avoid this possibility of d4
needing to choose which way to capture
black captures on f4 immediately bishop
captures on f4
and now knight to h5 knight h5 is just
tempoing the bishop so you have to move
it
and now after bishop e3 black plays
knight e5 when we get uh this very
heavy decision for white to make this
knight on e5 is hitting the bishop on c4
it's hitting the knight on f3 this
knight is of course pinned and this
bishop is just one of white's very nice
attacking pieces
so we need to take a moment to look at
the position and decide which move is
best to play
do we try and reinforce our bishop we
try to reinforce our knight
do we do something completely different
and the position gets
very wild after white takes on e5
but nick what's happening you know this
pin this pin that's been happening we're
going to lose our queen
well let's take a look at it after they
take our queen
we have three pieces that are targeting
the f7 pawn
so here the knight which is attacked
would make sense to capture with the
knight
you attack black's queen and
the the black king can't move if you try
something like queen d7
then knight to e5 is going to win the
queen
so this means black has to take with
their rook
and after they take with the rook rick
takes f7
and i'm giving this move an exclamation
mark if you don't play this it's going
to be more of an equal game but there's
a lot of threats happening here
so first king is on a light square
bishop's on a light square
so white is threatening multiple
discoveries to win the queen
so any queen move is going to
to lose almost right away so if you go
like queen to c8
rook c7 king is in check they have to
move and you win a queen
after they recapture white wins the
bishop
and here white is up a piece and pawns
they're going to have
a very happy time the only move that
really doesn't
i guess there's two moves that don't
follow this there's king h8
walking out of the discovery but after
rook takes d1
white has more than enough peace
activity this knight isn't
participating in the game this rook
while it does have an open file has no
targets
and then white can look at swinging the
rook over
and threatening some back row checks
the other move that doesn't really
follow this
is queen to b8 where there is no rook
discovery to win the queen
and here again white just takes on d1
and they have
more than enough compensation for what
looks to be a strong piece
that's actually not doing anything for
black
so this bishop to a g4 idea
while sharp can't lead to an equal
position i think i
missed the main move i can't show this
variation and not show the main move the
best move here is pawn to d5
and it looks very interesting black
looks like they're going down material
and they're just giving up a pawn
but it's very very important to disrupt
the coordination of the bishop and the
rook
now black has two threats taking the
bishop
and the rook white just takes with the
bishop
but now we see the black return this
sacrifice the queen takes on d5 pawn d5
king takes rook rook takes bishop and
here in this present moment it looks
like white is winning it looks like
white has two extra pawns
but let's not forget when the knight
took on b6 ages ago
it opened up this file for black's rook
and it gets to take on a2 for free here
now you have to play rook b1 so you
protect your pawn
and now after a move like knight f6
white is still slightly better
but now black is getting some counter
play and
uh if you're you know much stronger
rated
opponent or stronger rated than your
opponents rather
you may have chances to outplay in this
end game
so that is bishop to g4 the other idea
here
is knight to g4 and one of the
only master games i believe that has
this move is uh
frank versus crawl it ended in a draw in
2001.
knight g4 was played followed by knight
to g5
white is putting more pressure on f7 and
you'll notice in a lot of these lines f7
is a key point that white is trying to
hit upon in black's position
black castles the rook will help protect
f7
and now pawn to f5 this is again another
example of
cutting off the coordination of the
pieces so now this
knight is hanging and black has
this in-between move here bishop to f2
check
can't take it with the king because it's
protected by the knight so you have to
go king f1
after king f1 there's knight to e3 check
and here black will win the bishop pair
so again if black can trade off pawns it
may serve well
in the long run but here white can have
a very strong
attack after pawn h4
just rushing this pawn up trying to
wreck black's pawn structure
bishop g5 hg5 queen g5
another pawn sacrifice to open up the
position and we see rook to h5
tempoing the queen we see queen to f4
check and now instead of going queen f3
and trading off that would not help
white
we see king to g1 and here the engine
gives whites uh almost plus
one because of this crazy pressure on
the king's side
but if you're strong if you're black
you're strong you can
probably survive this and try and win in
the end game
let's say black tries to go for castles
this move is a little dubious
white can just play f5 and kind of clamp
down on the position make it very hard
for this bishop to develop
and that's really probably the only
other try that black has in this
position
white can try something like i guess
it's black's turn
there's a couple tactics here with
knight to
d4 so there are no tactics that exist i
was getting my coordinates mixed up
but at knight to d4 and sinking the
knight into the position
this position can be promising for black
maybe worth a look
okay so we're going to go back um that
covers
the knight f6 lines here
and that really covers the bishop to c4
ideas
white also has another very interesting
way to play
with pawn to g3 so one of the drawbacks
of knight to c6 is that it can be very
slow
you're not putting immediate pressure on
white center as if you would with knight
to f6
so white can adopt this slower more
positional style
of play with g3 they're looking to go
bishop to g2
and in these fiance lines is really
going to be a fight over the d5 square
white is going to try and clamp down on
the d5 square
and prevent black from breaking with
pawn to d5
so here we'll normally see bishop to c5
hitting the weak f2 square
bishop g2 and while black can play d6
here
try and open up the path for the bishop
this can run into knight a4
and just win the bishop pair right away
so if you care about your bishops
you may not want this to happen
so most players at the master level will
play a6 here that way if you run into
knight a4 just bishop a7
you keep your bishop pair you keep this
pressure on
f2 and play these positions
so after d6 sorry a6
knight g to e2 white is going to
continue these kind of standard
development ideas
you'll see the knight go to e2 in a lot
of these lines
they're going to try and build for an f4
break after d3
and castles again this is going to be
tough to achieve with the bishop on c5
so after castles king h1 is going to be
necessary at some point
now we see black play d6 because we
couldn't do it earlier with knight a4
white goes pawn to d3 opening up the
path for the bishop
and it would like to go to e3 naturally
however
if you go bishop to e3 in the near
future black can trade
and then you're going to have these
doubled pawns in the center which
while not a bad thing it's not great
white really wants to go for this f4
push and break open
the position black will develop the
knight
not going to f6 because that would run
into bishop g5 it would be a very easy
square for white to develop the dark
square bishop too
so they go e7 and after castles from
both sides
this is a very equal position and
probably a great position to play if you
feel like you can outplay your opponent
there aren't too many things to worry
about so if you you just
are a better positional player and can
outplay your opponent this is a very
good position to go for
and then i probably should mention that
after knight to c6
i believe i talked about f4 but yeah if
they take
after knight f3 uh standard development
e5 doesn't exist um
this is fine for for both sides but
black may have some more pressure than
normal
okay and then i believe i talked about
d6 um but that might have been in a
different position
so instead the knight moves if black
tries pawn to d6
bishop to c4 again resembling a philidor
pawn structure
after knight to f6 pawn to d3
white will just have very fine play with
normal development
and that covers i believe all of the
knight c6
lines so
we'll jump back into the meat of this
with knight f6 and go into the vienna
gambit
if black isn't careful they can easily
be overwhelmed
so again if they take pawn e5 the knight
has to go back
knight f3 d6 pawn d4
take you pin the pawn maintain your
pressure in the center
and then you win your pawn back and
trade off queens and you have a fun end
game where you're developed and your
opponent is not
so black can't really take there
now what happens if they try and defend
the pawn
well let's start with a direct pawn to
d6
after pawn to d6 knight to f3
knight c6 just developing the knights
for both sides
white has bishop to b5 stopping the
knight from jumping into d4
and encouraging black to play bishop d7
and now pawn to d3 this is going to
resemble a bit more of those
knight c6 plans that we went over
earlier uh
so now what if we try knight c6 to save
the pawn
here um this is actually very bad for
black
the refutation is f takes e5 and after
knight takes e5
we get what's like a halloween gambit
except we didn't even have to
sacrifice the knight so for those of you
who don't know what the halloween gamba
is
it's in the four nights where white will
sacrifice this piece and played d4
hoping for a massive initiative here we
see that kind of idea
after knight to c6 but instead of having
to sacrifice the knight we just get this
position
by trading pawns so here after knight g6
pawn to e5
this knight has to go back to g8 and
after knight to f3
white just has a very nice big center
knights are developed bishops are going
to come out
castle king's side or queen side
and white stands much better here
so is knight c6 and let's say instead of
knight c6 they go bishop d6 some
beginners might try and protect the pawn
this way
this goes against the general principle
of blocking your center pawns with your
pieces you generally don't want to do
this
but here it also doesn't work tactically
because pawn takes and if the bishop
takes
white hits them with d4 and there's
nowhere for this dark square bishop to
go
there's a bishop to f4 bishop to g3 both
of those are protected
and after bishop to d6 white can just
play
pawn to e5 forking the pieces
and if queen e7 to pin the pawn
then white can just go queen e2
unpinning the pawn
this threat still stands and white is
going to win a piece
so the vienna gambit after f4 black
can't
accept it black shouldn't defend the
pawn
what are you supposed to do well
you play d5 strike in the center
and you want to try and get your
development out this way
try and bring some very sharp combat to
the scene to counteract
white's aggressive attack
here the main move is take on e5
you're going to misplace the knight the
knight is going to go
take on e4 and now
queen to f3 there are other moves that
white can play here like knight f3 is
fine
taking is kind of equal but i like queen
f3 because it introduces pressure
right away to f7 and if they take on c3
you have the option to take with either
pawn or the queen
here we do have a bunch of moves
from black so we will start with knight
to c6
knight to c6 looks like a very natural
move you're going to come and take on e5
and this really leaves white with only
one option here is a bishop to b5
pinning the knight you have to pin the
knight that way it can't
take tempo the queen here you'll see
knight takes c3
d takes you're opening up the path for
your bishop
queen h4 track g3 to block the check
and queen to e4
and here we do have two options for
white
we have the move queen takes e4 which
was seen in the game
uh adamko febby in 2009
and that uh was black winning but the
position here
black is only slightly better after this
main line where black will take on e4
bishop develops to e3 white is ready to
castle
bishop d7 bishop takes because now that
the pin is broken
the knight could have taken on e5 so you
have to trade the bishop for the knight
knight e2 g6 looking to bring the bishop
to g7 and hit e5
castle is long bishop g7 again
trying to go for this pawn knight d4
if black can successfully take this pawn
without losing the bishop pair
these bishops are going to be monsters
so you have to be able to trade your
knight off
for one and be able to get some counter
play on these doubled pawns
bishop d4 will force a trade and you
want to force this trade because it will
result in white having
active rook placement f5 to save the
pawn and now rook
h to d1 and here
we enter a rook and the game where white
is down upon
but in exchange for that pawn they have
very
very active rooks the rooks are going to
come in on the seventh rank
and try and clean up these pawns just
being
careful of this e-pawn this is a past
pawn this is going to be the one black
is going to try to promote
but with careful play this position
should be
fairly close to equal
the other move instead of trading queens
right away
is a bit of a trappy move where you can
play bishop to e3 and block the check
if they take on f3 and the knight takes
this is just good for white
because black is helping white develop
and here you will see
white has three developed pieces four
blacks one
so the real trouble comes if black tries
to start taking these pawns on the queen
side
here in this position white will develop
with knight to e2
and for example if black just tries to
take these pawns they are losing on the
spot
after castle's king side we can't forget
that we've allowed this f-file to open
so this introduces
mate threats and if you stop the mate
with bishop to e6
knight to d4 is going to put pressure on
c6
it defends the bishop from the queen and
puts pressure on e6
so imagine white can just take black
takes back and queen f7 check
is going to be annoying
so those are two different ways for
white to play
the other move in this position after
queen f3
is pawn to f5 and one of the games that
features this
um this line is yip uh krista yep versus
justin wong in the southwest
open 2019 so the most recent game
and black won this game as well but
white does here
is uh hits the knight trades off the
knights and plays d4
sorry black plays d4 if black plays
something like e7 or sorry bishop e6
then pawn to d4 and white is going to
enjoy a space advantage
nice pawn chain something that uh this
pawn structure is like a
winner or a french so black has to play
d4 um to avoid this
uh d4 is a bit of a slow move from black
though after pawn to d4
white punishes black for their slow play
by playing queen to g3
and it makes it extremely difficult for
black to develop their bishop
and here there's two different move
orders to get to the same position
but knight c6 is the more popular move
order here after knight c6 there's
bishop to e2
this bishop is going to make its way to
f3
it's very important that you don't put
the knight on f3 that is the most
important diagonal for this bishop
and you have to bring the bishop there
first because otherwise if knight e2 you
just block the path for the bishop
bishop e2 now bishop e6 developing
bishop to f3 queen d7 and now black is
prepared to castle queenside
knight to e2 and now pawn takes c3
we can let this sit here as white this
pawn will be a target for a while
so instead of focusing on taking this
pawn back right away we should continue
developing the pieces
bishop to e3 knight to b4
attacking both pawns he had to go rook
to c1 to save the pawn
and here black is slightly better
for some more beginner players you might
be wondering why they can't take on a2
and the reason for this is uh bishop
takes b7
and white will get some counter play add
a rook to b8
queen to f3 protecting the bishop and
you can sacrifice this
uh this rook here because of this
pin you will pin the queen to the king
winning the queen
and having an interesting material
imbalance
so that is another way for black to play
they can play f5
but the main line here after queen to f3
is
knight takes c3 and there's multiple
ways for white to capture
but the the capture i'm going to
recommend here is b takes c3
and again the idea is you're going to
play d4 get this nice space advantage
have a nice strong pawn sensor
easy development so bishop e7 getting
ready to castle king side
pawn to d4 and now castles
from black black can also try for an
early c5 but if they play c5 before they
castle
white can just go bishop d3 pawn to c4
this bishop goes to f5 and trades itself
off
queen d7 trade the queens off and after
knight e2
we enter this end game where while
material is equal
you know white has this space advantage
it's pretty easy to get the pieces out
like a4 bishop a3
the knight can go to f4 and hit d5
so that end game uh could be equal for
both sides by
i feel like white stands slightly better
so black should go for castles
and now bishop to d3
after bishop to d3 we have um three very
interesting continuations
uh the purpose of bishop to d3 is to put
pressure on h7
and we'll show why this is important so
let's say black plays
what looks to be a natural move looks
like bishop e6
is completely fine you're protecting f7
protecting your center this is great
however this introduces the idea of
queen to h5
and this may look fine at first you know
you can play g6
stop the mate threat queen goes to h6
you might have ideas of bishop to g5 and
f6 in the future
you can't do that right now because of
the queen and bishop but you're going to
run the h
pawn down sacrifice the h pawn with some
big mate threats something resembling
the french defense gone wrong in the
winor
or some ideas in the dragon with the
fiancee bishop you're going to run this
h-pawn down
and sacrifice it so
black's best idea is to try and kick
this queen out right away
so they do it with rook to e8 and then
after knight f3 bishop to f8
now queen to f4 more pressure on f7 and
after c5 knight to g5 white does have a
very promising position the computer is
putting it uh white at about plus one
and a half
some positions plus two and again the
idea is just rush your h-pawn down
and rip open black's king side
instead of playing bishop to e6 one try
black has here which can lead to a
forced
draw is pawn to f6
so pawn to f6 here is an idea that you
can see in the french sometimes whenever
they try and attack
the head of the pawn chain trying to rip
open the position that way and now if we
see queen to h5 black has pawn to g6
and now bishop takes g6 hg6
queen g6 you run into a draw by
repetition
so king to h8 queen to h6 king to g8
queen to g6 this is your forced drawn
move
13.
okay let's say you're playing black and
you don't want to go for the force draw
you're trying to win this position
well after bishop to d3 you should play
pawn to c5
trying to get your space on the queen
side you're not necessarily going to try
and capture
but really just try and clamp down the
position where white is going to have
space on the king side black is going to
have space
on the queen side here knight to e2
and after c4 this bishop is not really
trapped don't worry
just bishop to f5 and now bishop takes
queen takes
and you'll see another queen exchange
and
here we end up in another similar
position
similar end game where white will have
the pressure
on the d5 pawn black will start to have
pressure
on the queen side after possibly running
their queens up the board
and this is probably one of the better
tries for black is to go for this end
game
which is equal only giving white
plus 0.2 or 0.3 depending on the depth
but that is pretty much the gist
of e4 e5 knight c3 that is almost
everything possible in the vienna for
those lines that i recommended
some of black's best tries as you can
see there's a lot of very
strong attacks some very natural looking
moves for black that are just complete
blunders
so if you are black and you play e5 this
is definitely an opening you're going to
want to study and look for those traps
make sure you're not going to fall for
them
and as white i would really recommend
this opening for blitz
just because there are all these traps
black can fall into and they
can give some very interesting positions
but that is it for the vienna gambit
this is it for
chess openings explained i want to thank
everyone for stopping in
we're going to move over to twitch for
some tactics we'll see you over there
and i'll see you next week for the
openings
[Music]
you